you will notice that this chandelier is
shaking a little bit because John that
was an earthquake
welcome to Los Angeles I'm standing in a
doorway because I hear that's what
you're supposed to do so I guess that
wasn't a big one that shamble are you
sure still is movin though that's not I
guess that's not that impressive it felt
very impressive at the time John you
know the earth is supposed to be
something you're able to trust let's
just stay in the same place that's all I
ask like how much more could I ask from
the earth okay also supply us with an
infinite amount of abundant fossil fuels
do that to earth okay the earth does a
lot for us and we don't do a lot for it
so I guess maybe every once in a while
it's entitled to a little bit of shaken
but man I bet that was like a 1 on the
Richter scale and my heart's beating
like crazy John
this is James at war I don't know if you
remember James at war but he made a
stint of amazingly popular parody videos
so I decided that I would uh interview
him because there's youtubers and he's
the first one that I actually ran into
randomly so what's up we had an
earthquake earlier today and it made a
button fall off my jacket the earthquake
made a button you just shook I shook and
a button fell off my jacket that's what
I'm claiming happened anyway is it
possible that your jacket just thought
that it had too many buttons on it and
the jacket that is entirely possible
just a jacket thought it was too gaudy
and just said I'm out right it's the
thing I think it's much more appropriate
now mm-hmm you look like you're 12 but I
know that you have a lot of kids so how
did that work I started when I was 6 and
nobody taught me about prophylactics so
5 kids at the age of 18 you have 5 kids
I have 5 kids and you live in Alaska
right now yeah I do why do you live in
Alaska uh Air Force sent me up there by
choice I put it down to some place I'd
like to go well actually moving to
Alaska where there is nothing to do in
the wintertime at least and my wife
worked as a manager at a club and they
played the same songs over and over and
over again so she came home and she
would say I hate this song I hate this
song so I decided to write different
words to the songs
just for her and so I wrote a song
called popstar and I wrote a song called
hey Harry Potter and it was right at
this time I discovered YouTube even
existed and so I thought well hey I
might as well just throw these on
YouTube as well and so I threw them on
there and both of them went viral which
completely took me by surprise and the
rest is history I just kept on writing
songs mostly for my wife that's that's
adorable
so and then you kind of thing kind of
stopped yeah I stopped because of course
America is doing the war on terror and
the Air Force which is my profession the
up tempo just went way up and I just got
entirely too busy and if you if you are
in the military and you don't want to be
busy don't get promoted YouTube
unfortunately had to take a back burner
to the profession of arms is that going
to change that is going to change you
coming back I'm coming back yeah I'm
getting out in August and I'm counting
down the days or anything full-time
writing full-time videos and all kinds
of new exciting stuff I cannot wait so
do you have any plans I mean there's new
Harry Potter movies coming out there's
new Twilight movies out there's all
kinds of awesome new games coming out
and of course that's kind of my niche
and that's that's the stuff I'm into and
dorka PHY popular song that's right I am
the door because a dork is somebody
who's kind of into everything but not
really good at anything and that's that
to me thank you for coming on our
channel and talking about what's going
on with James at war and we're looking
forward to having you back thank you for
coming to VidCon thank you I can't wait
for it to start and be over with so I
can make a video done